>>> TURNING NOW TO THE WAR IN
UKRAINE AND R NEXT GUEST, WHO
IS A RUSSIAN AUTHOR, JOURNALIST
AND NOW A WANTED MAN.
LAST WEEK THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT
NAMED HIM A FOREIGN AGENT FOR
HIS CRITICISM OF VLADIMIR
PUTIN'S WAR AGAINST UKRAINE.
DEMITRI, FOUR MONTHS AGO A
MOSCOW COURT ORDERED YOUR ARREST
FOR ALLEGEDLY DISCREDITING THE
RUSSIAN ARMED FORCES.
TELL US MORE ABOUT WHY YOU HAVE
DRAWN THE IRE OF VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> WELL, ACTUALLY THERE'S BEEN A
CAMPAIGN TO PERSECUTE PRETTY
MUCH A LOT OF PUBLIC
PERSONALITIES WHO OPPOSE THE
WAR.
FOR ME, THE SOURCE WAS PRETTY
OBVIOUS.
I HAD A LOT OF FRIENDS IN
UKRAINE.
IT WAS VERY BLACK AND WHITE
SITUATION FOR ME.
I COULDN'T KEEP MY MOUTH SHUT,
UNFORTUNATELY, FOR THEM OR FOR
ME.
STILL SOMETHING I DON'T REGRET
AT ALL.
BASICALLY I'VE USED MY INSTAGRAM
ACCOUNT AND OTHER SOCIAL MEDIA
AND I WROTE A NUMBER OF
ARTICLES, OPINION ARTICLES FOR
THE GUARDIAN AND DEADLINE,
CRITICIZING THE WAR AND CALLING
THE WAR A WAR.
THAT'S ALREADY A CRIME.
YOU'LL BE ACCUSED OF
DISCREDITING THE RUSSIAN ARMED
FORCES WHEN YOU SAY THEY'RE
RESPONSIBLE OF BOMBING UKRAINIAN
CITIES.
YOU'RE FACING UP TO 15 YEARS IN
JAIL, LIKE IN MY CASE BECAUSE I
PERSONALLY ACCUSED VLADIMIR
PUTIN FOR BEING RESPONSIBLE FOR
UNLEASHING THIS WAR.
>> SO YOU MENTIONED THE ARTICLE.
I WANT TO READ AN EXCERPT FROM
IT.
YOU URGED YOUR FELLOW RUSSIANS
TO, QUOTE, NOT BELIEVE THE LIES
AND DEMAND THE TRUTH, TO STICK
OUT LIKE A SORE THUMB, TO
DEBATE, TO STAND UP FOR OUR
DIGNITY.
ARE ENOUGH OF YOUR FELLOW
RUSSIANS WILLING TO RISK WHAT
YOU'RE RISKING, YOUR FREEDOM OR
MORE?
>> YOU NEVER KNOW, YOU KNOW.
I HOPE THERE IS A LONG WAITING
LINE BEFORE ME AND THOSE GUYS
WHO ARE WAITING FOR THEIR
EXTRADITION HEARING.
SO FAR I'M RISKING AN ARREST AND
UP TO 15 YEARS IN JAIL IF I'M
GOING ANYWHERE NEAR RUSSIA, LIKE
RUSSIA FORMER CIS BECAUSE THEY
DO COLLABORATE AND EXTRADITE.
THERE ARE CASES IN RUSSIA OF
ALSO ARTISTS BEING NOT ONLY
BOOED BUT ALSO POISONED BEFORE,
SUCH AS A FAMOUS RUSSIAN AUTHOR
WHO WAS POISONED WITH THE SAME
AGENT AS ALEXEI NAVALNY AHEAD OF
HIM A COUPLE OF YEARS BEFORE.
SO THINGS DO HAPPEN.
>> YOU MUST BE WORRIED FOR YOUR
SAFETY.
>>
YOU CAN NEVER FEEL SAFE WHEN
YOU'RE CRITICIZED THE
AUTHORITIES IN RUSSIA, BUT I
THINK THEY SHOULD BE IN DECIDING
WHO THEY SHOULD ELIMINATE FIRST.
I WILL SAY WHEN IT'S POSSIBLE TO
KEEP YOUR MOUTH SHOUT BUT NOT IN
A CASE WHEN YOUR COUNTRY IS
UNLEASHING UNDER FALSE PRETENSE,
MADE UP PREDATORY WAR AGAINST
ITS NEIGHBOR RULING 1,000 YEARS
OF RELATIONS JUST BECAUSE A
PERSON WANTS TO INSCRIBE HIS
NAME IN THE HISTORY BOOKS AS
SOMEBODY WHO REUNITED THE ONCE